it's okay to murder absolutely yeah I
actually think that all kids should get
murdered
[Music]
God of them are wrong but all of them
are wrong okay but abortion I do believe
it is murder
but like that's okay it's okay to murder
absolutely yeah really okay talk to me I
actually think that old kids should get
maded kids wait all kids be
yeah yeah why they cost too much yeah
they're bad for the environment kids yes
they they're actually really healthy for
the environment they're actually not
yeah they C they cause a lot of families
uh you know a lot of health and
happiness that is not that's not the
environment happiness they're complet
two different things what what do you
think the environment is what do you
mean climate change joking that children
have nothing to do with climate change
yes they do really yeah the more people
on this planet the more it's dying so so
just to be clear you agree that abortion
is murder you're just saying it's okay
absolutely okay and you said everything
on here is wrong yeah everything yeah so
so no God n no Bible no Jes joking no so
you're an y okay so how did you get here
then a drove here
what what do you mean how did how did
you come into existence I was born yeah
but how did you get here into life into
existence okay I we humans came from
monkeys and that came from Evolution you
was came from monkeys absolutely
according to what evolution yeah but
wait but you're saying EV according to
what cuz Evolution the your type of
evolution is like science fiction no
it's not it is there's there's no other
there's absolutely no evidence that you
was ever a monkey yeah there is what
what what is there yeah it's in museums
are you joking no it's not IM M yes it
is yes it is evolved Evolution okay all
right so let me gr you this let's say
evolution is real yeah all right it is
real how did how did Evolution begin cuz
that's life yeah natural you're saying
natural selection that's life still
Accord so if you're saying science one
of the scientific laws is that life does
not come from non-life life always come
from Life yes so if natural selection
was is you know a started Evolution and
stuff like that that's life where did it
originate where does life originate uh
something happens with some yeah with
some organisms but if there's again if
there's molecules and there's life I can
where life come from Aliens okay all
right but here we are again where do the
aliens come from not from God that's
okay you're saying not from God then
from what cuz you got something we don't
know yet we don't know okay let me ask
you this okay so would you say that this
this thing that we don't know yeah okay
where did God come from okay so good
question oh God what oh God oh God hey
I'm ready for you sis yeah I can out all
right I'm ready for but I I like your
question so if it's a serious question I
can answer it yeah answer it okay so
here's the here's the answer so where
does God come from so God by definition
is eternal he created time he created
space what do you mean how can one how
can one person do that if they're all
powerful they can do that right if look
for in order for but but how did he get
here if you're saying life it comes from
Life yeah life comes from life so he
would have to be the infinite life the
source of life that doesn't make sense
how does it not where did he come from
though if he if he's always existed he's
there is no where did he come from he
always been no no no you're just
contradicting yourself how you you said
life comes from Life how does God just
exist when not coming from something
else okay so notice the notice the
statement life life comes from life
right so whenever life begins to exist
its source is in life itself so there's
a source of life where life is coming
from so there is you're just talking now
how you're absolutely talking some smack
you ain't got nothing to say absolutely
no because you're saying that good has
already existed but where did he come
from you're just contradicting yourself
he can't already exist okay all right so
let's break this down let's break this
down this is my my statement okay
whatever begins to exist has a cause
okay whatever begins to exist something
started it okay whatever begins to exist
so something had to start God ex
something had to start life cuz life
began to exist at some point yeah God
organisms yeah good but organisms have
to come from a life what I'm saying
about God God did not begin to exist so
God doesn't have a cause he's the
uncaused cause he's has always been
where do you get this stuff uh you know
it's funny science I actually get it
from Absolut example no way no watch the
universe is 14 billion years old you
know that right yeah sure okay so the so
so the universe has a beginning so that
means time space matter energy it all
began at some point that means that it
has a cause from The Big Bang no the big
the big Bane is the beginning so so so
something caused the universe to come
into being okay so whatever this cause
is just just hear me out okay here's the
universe time space matter energy right
that's the universe it All Began so
whatever caused the universe to begin
caused time to begin it caused energy it
caused matter the the physical world so
whatever calls these things has to be
outside of them so the cause has to be
timeless meaning Eternal the cause has
to be immaterial which we might say
physical or metaphysical right spiritual
sorry um the cause has to be all
powerful in order to start all of this
so what would you call that cause not
God what would you call it then science
science science is pointing to this
cause yeah yeah I definitely wouldn't
say that it's caused by a singular
person though why not because that's
just silly okay so let me ask you this
is there I'm I'm going prove to you that
the cause of the universe is a person
it's personal show you how yeah good um
anything that we look at and speaking of
science science begins with observation
right that's a scientific method begins
with observation so in all of your human
observation is there ever something that
is able to produce something that itself
doesn't have can something produce
something that it doesn't have
already I don't know I haven't thought
about it but the answer would be no okay
right everything would everything that
comes from something would have a source
and whatever source is producing
something has to have those properties
within itself or else it can't produce
that thing okay make sense yeah okay so
the cause of the universe the cause of
you and me It produced personal beings
you're a person I'm a person all
billions of people right do you think
just people popped into
existence say that again you think that
like humans just like popped into
existence I don't believe that humans
popped into existence I believe that God
created humans and the Bible says that
he made the first man from dirt molded
him and and and created him in his image
why did he create them so late then all
right pause here we're going to wait for
them to pass okay
yeah I I really like you though you're I
like you I like her best guest today
best best guest
today that let's get
the yeah I do have a flight to catch
okay yeah well it is this was fun take
care
okay what
[Applause]
why oh my God logic
[Music]
oh